unequal time like the sounds like
to unfold the saint but from the front
[Music]
how it looks like new york series is
annoying there are many things in trinks of
this warehouse I'm giovanni valdés and one
about a second
ok I was born in the Dominican Republic I
was going to  the radio station and I
like everything I want to do this I moved to
new york in 1999 well I started
radio here 4 years ago
there is no winery that I know of that
has a radio like me here in the winery I
am a  animal of that
already automatically among the radios is
dj yoga
everything is r lambie fm and I go to the cabin the
dilemma licks my lips I tell them a word
that we are going to say freud
flirt flirtatious then we already got
names from tram fm because we deserved
the shipment and change the  name
good afternoon live my works represents
the latin community here in brooklyn is
new york we have a range of more or less from
40,000 to 60,000 people he tried to
please everyone a little with his music
an urban music
a  to romantic music
merengue
bachata
little classical music
so I decided to bring it all to a
single radio
[Music]
forward fm we are more focused not
only music is an option
involved with the community is new
york' a long time ago it was a
very bad area I say that  We were going to invite the
people to listen to the radio to the
community meetings and try to
fix the problems that we have here.
We want to remind you that
whatever concerns you have, it is
very important that you attend the
meetings,
thanks to the people of 375 and in the
community of that.  together with
us we are doing a
good job, the support we are
having in the community after the
radio
[Music]